あの超人気ユーチューバーのじゅんやさん
に登録が抜かれましたね闘茶数順やが肇
社長は越したあー甫じゅんやさんに登録者
住む化されとる僕もなんか悔しい2つめ
頑張って人間数字だけじゃないよ
[音楽]
気にしちゃんだろうそんなこと言われたら
知事したんだろう
気にしてありがとう気にしてありがとう絹
してありがとう
こんにちははじめ冊をですね抜かされまし
たとも皆さんあの
頑張って気にしないようにしてたのに
ありがとうみんな心配してくれてるん
でしょ心配してくれてるの本当に
ありがとう本当に頑張って急にしないよう
に人は人自分は自分ってこう気にしない
ように人を気にしないように頑張って
youtube やろうと思ったらなんか
抜かれた瞬間いろんな人に抜かれたぬかれ
たの彼らのからってきたら霧さあでしょ
んすいません取り乱しましたはいはーい
いやほんとありがとうございますあの
ありがたいんですけどごめんな厳しいなん
で言われたら余計気にして昨日抜かれて
からツイッター見ないようにしましたと
いうわけでなんかいちいちこのねぇ抜いた
ぬかれたの話を動画にするのもなんだと
思うんですけど結構いろんな人に純也さん
に抜かれたって言われたんだよこれ話すは
皆さん気になると思うんで僕の心境とか
今日話させていただきます
ずやってだレアどこのどいつやー
知らん知らんこともないけど知らんことも
ないけど
注意やってちょっと待ってああいっ
迫った俺がなかったってことはもう10日
イオンやとかヴィシャールとかあそこの編
を群を抜いているわけですからね5迫って
きたそんな純やって人ちょっと10年も
よくわかってないんでちょっと見させて
いただきます
もうもらいや糖度もないよずるいってもう
純役キャッチない今せるの淳矢君はもう
チャンネル登録者数は90062万人動画
のホース船団たくなっちゃうパチもんわー
こんな私を超えるということは相当凄い人
なんですよ
おおぉケッ
こうを出してるなんて工賃頻度が24時間
前に出した動画がもう9本10分がやるぞ
ちょっと見てみましょうかあ
本日に強化とりました本当に今日は取っ
てるんであのー怒らないでくださいね
ちょっと見ますよ
多分そうじゃないか楽しそうじゃない海
だれよでも保つトウヤはここ最近見た
ユーチューバーの中であの
知らないっていうのは出た嘘でもちろん
知ってますよさが迫り来るすごい勢いの
あるクリエイターたにいらっしゃるのはで
見てもらったら分かる通り純矢くんですね
ティックトックも動画だしててあの短い
動画
[音楽]
俺は好きなんですよ結構ながこの短い立
動画のショートどうだって言うの短い動画
はめちゃくちゃすごい頻度で上げている方
が矛盾100均千夏は気になっちゃう入ら
なくね
ペンギン
ん
[音楽]
と言うんですね一瞬でパッと見れるアップ
テンポのどうぞずっと出されている方なん
ですけども再生化してみて5.1ば3.2
も3匹も3年47万8.5万
たっ通りゃ内海動画などレジャー買ってる
んですけどもこの人何がすごいかっていう
と鍵がいいで貼ってるんですよヒカキン
さんとか僕と彼も日本タイプなんですけど
も人脈がもう海外ではずっと人記事にして
みてみようか一番凄いのでもう1.9よく
回再生9ヶ月前に出したこの1.5億開催
者が見てみましょうか
いいいいいい
[音楽]
ああ
9位フードで235万いいなんですよもう
あの子の型を日本をもう見てないやミクで
このスレませんけどわかんないけどもう
海外でウケているっていう感じなんですよ
完全にです何かユーチューバーという感じ
なのかはちょっとわかんないんですけど俺
とかヒカキンさんだもう完全に立ち位置が
違うタイプですねジャンルは違うというか
も闘ってるあの世界が違うと人気順にし
たらすごいんですけども新しいずにすると
やっぱり1本あたりのその再生数は低かっ
たりするんですけどヒカキンさんとか僕は
日本に向かってこうやってしっかりと
ストレートパンチ打っていくんですけども
腎炎とは4階に向けて
細い目に見えないマッハパンチを打ち
まくっていくという感じそれ本当は日本で
ko するより海外で形容した方が話題に
なるんですよ日本で形容しても日本の
ニュースにしかないんですけど世界に計を
取った時はもう世界ニュースになるわけで
それが彼のすごいところなんですよ
ティックトップ出身だったからもう立て
動画もうひたすらショート動画たしまくっ
てすごいもうほんと努力したいると思うよ
このスピード感こんなにだ専門棟が
ちょっとあの言い方悪いですけどちょっと
の面白くてクスッと笑えるなく取らないん
動画をめちゃ組んだしまくってしっかりと
世界にぶち当たって戦っていくという恒子
ございますか方がやっぱこのキャッチーな
んだろうなぁ入っていう純役にですね
ちょっと抜かれてしまいましたまた悔しい
と違うすぎな感じですねこれまたあの
抜かれちゃったねっていうことでまぁ抜か
れてはいるんですけどみなさんが思ってる
そんな気にしてないからもう自分のペース
で自分らしく1000万に行きたいなと
思っているし誰にとっても美味しいことに
ですね動画にの仕事すごい起きてここ最近
の3日間がもう朝から晩まで全部別のお
仕事を自分のチャンネルに関係ないお仕事
してていろんな方に必要とされるの
とっても嬉しいし僕も焦らずに自分の
ペースで1000万人目させればいいかな
と思っていますいきたいんですよねいき
たいんですけどねこの忙しい中もやり動画
とってもちょっとアレだなと思って自分の
ペースで頑張っていこうってちょっと動画
だしたいけども今は目先の仕事をしっかり
やろうと思ってご自分に言い聞かせていた
最中ヌカザナからてんだかれたって言われ
てあー見てる人はすごい気にしてるんだな
と思ってあの動画にさせていただきました
純矢くんねー
誰だよこのクスッと笑える勢いなる動画が
さパパって見るのが本当に俺が結構好きで
チャンネル登録者さんでくれてましたけど
ね行った家とも日本というよりなく世界の
人っていう優勝がボクマガですごい強かっ
たですあのー
抜かれても
あまり言わないでねちょっとまだ押すごと
バリバリありますけども1000万円
目指して頑張りたいと思います逆に抜かれ
たというお話でございましたまあ
とりあえず1000万人目がちょっと最近
は忙しいんですけどれるべき事をしっかり
この視点着実に目指したいと思います
じゃあなー
[音楽]